last one I was on I got a tiny piece on
what uh you and mop were talking about
that with for example tattoos being uh
part of it with women being related to
trauma um so I wanted to hear more on um
uh what your correlation is that it's
something new to me I never heard that
before I'm very curious I I don't have
any tatto
tattoos U so I was curious about the
trauma part uh connected to him it's
it's just correlated you know whenever
you
sorry whenever I have in my personal
experience and whenever I've dealt with
guys in their personal experience women
that have covered themselves with
tattoos like a sticker book they just
tattoo random [__] like all over their
body um it's like their representations
of something and it's you know I
mentioned this um I don't know if it's
was on the last show that you were on or
one prior or after that but I was
talking to this guy on his podcast
Elliot hul some of you guys watching are
probably you know familiar with name one
of the things that he said that also was
a bit of a punch to the gut beyond what
I've already talked about with tattoos
with it being associated with some some
form of trauma that you know is
accumulated is you actually have to sit
still in a chair for hours at a time
while a man penetrates your
body doing these little dots putting
these you know coloring in and all this
sort of stuff and I've never met a woman
covered in tattoos that doesn't have
trauma you know like excessive piercings
that doesn't have trauma like you know
the brings all the way down the ears and
the septums and the nipples and all the
other body parts you know sort of thing
um there's always a direct correlation
it's not artwork it's not anything that
I've seen you know beyond that uh I
think that's one of the points that moff
made too when it was brought up as well
in the past is that you know he had a I
mean like I'll let you speak for
yourself but I mean you made the point
that you had a thing for you know women
with ink at one point you started to
realize dating them that they all have
baggage right they all have this
unnecessary baggage so it's one of the
items that ended up on my red flag list
number 10 was tattoos and excessive
piercing I
think I think minimalist you know like
versions of it like you know you want to
tattoo your uh you know your your
favorite dog's name because he went too
quickly or a paw or something like that
you know like no big deal you know um
something with a small genuine Gest but
when it's excessive and like I've had
women on the show like I had this one
gon one she was in her 50s and she was
tattooed from head to toe um she had
tattoos on her face and and her face was
the only part of her body that she had
the tattoos removed from I think lasered
off or or bleached or maybe she had
makeup on I can't remember what she said
but it was but it was her face that
looked like the only clear part but she
had tattoos from head to toe and she's
like I've been disqualified for jobs
I've been disqualified by men I've not
been taken seriously I've been treated
differently in medical
facilities um and she had trauma like
she had a tremendous amount of trauma
you know because of the tattoo so when I
tell guys you know like this is a red
flag it's just like look guys you know
keep your life simple if you can avoid
red flags and not invite women into your
life personally uh that that have a lot
of red flags then your life will be
better for it and it's not like you
can't date a gal with tattoos uh you can
it's just you know if she's got a whole
bunch of them chances are you're
probably going to deal with some
[__] in your
life so that's all
that that's what I think I'm seeing kind
of also in the dating World hearing it
from the women's sides is just kind of
I'm seeing what kind of what they're
doing with trauma for example like like
I said you know I've got mine but but I
made it a very conscious decision um
kind of like putting the bag down like
you said um and I figured out how to do
that for myself one of the things that
I've noticed um and I've mentioned this
to a few guys now is that women will
start tattooing like sayings and phrases
on their body right like they'll do it
all the way down their arm and some you
know like scripti sort of thing or in a
different language or something like
that it has some meaning to some phrase
that they want to memorize or you know
something like that it's like you can
write that [__] on a whiteboard you know
you can get a a poster you know like the
holti Manifesto was one of the big ones
that was you know done back in the day
but when they started writing this [__]
all over their body it's like you know I
remember when my daughter was like
little she would write stuff on a know
piece of paper and draw and half the
time she was drawing on her hand and her
body and like that's what it reminds me
of
right it's interesting too where it kind
of the tattoo if it's if it's connected
to some kind of baggage then I'm I'm
curious as to why does that person want
a a constant reminder of that it seems
like the constant reminder would hold
him back my opinion though yeah well
what I tell you know people is we all
have wounds but make your wounds your
work right you don't have to write them
on your body well my best friend lost
her husband um in February he was
epileptic and um seizure-free for 11
years and passed away unexpectedly at
work so she got a tattoo and Memorial of
him and then three months after um he
passed away her 2-year-old daughter with
Down Syndrome was diagnosed with
leukemia so she got a a tattoo in
remembrance of both of them and she's in
full remission now so what you're saying
about tattoos and women I think you
should really look into it a little more
um I think a lot of a lot of girls start
them because it is something sentimental
it is something they want to look at
every day especially someone that passes
away so instead of just traumas yes that
is a trauma but she also lost her
husband of 13 years got it and you know
that's a noble thing to do but at the
same time if I met her and we were
dating and she had some uh momento of
her ex-husband tattooed on her body to
me I would I mean if I was dating
multiple women simultaneously in a non-
monogamous fashion I was letting the
cream rise to the top because I was
looking for a long-term relationship I
would probably disqualify the lady with
the tattoo of her husband's name birth
date of birth date of death
death on her body so like it was the
mountains in the sea and then it was
like the Year date under it and it was
the first tattoo she's ever got and and
every time I see her naked then I would
be thinking well she's tattooed this man
like she's basically Alpha widowed by
this guy like this guy holds a place in
her heart well it's her husband and
father of her children so I think like I
understand but if you're going to move
on in life and you want to find another
man tattooing something to do with
another man on your body is not the best
idea my my husband and I kind of had
that discussion because his disability
is um it's something he could either
still live with another 20 30 years or
he could die tomorrow um and with him we
had the discussion where he says that
that did really does happen he told me
he wants me to get back out there and
find and find someone and to be happy
with and and my rebuttal back to him was
well that's gon to be pretty damn tough
since he's the best out there but but
that was a conversation that we end if
you don't get to have that conversation
and it happens suddenly wouldn't you
well so no that's the point is that we
wanted to have that conversation he
brought it up didn't answer my question
this happen question that she was
married and that her they didn't have
the opportunity to discuss tattoos if he
passed away because it was unexpected he
was 38 years old and he was very healthy
so what happened it wasn't pre-planned
he didn't have any pre-diagnosis it
happened because he was seizure free and
did not take his medicine and died at
work and it was a freak accident so she
did not get that opportunity with her
husband which I'm glad that you did but
she also had two children with him so I
think her putting him on a part of her
body is special to her and I don't think
that should be a a red flag for anyone I
think that's a sign it is choices you
can't tell a man not to disqualify a
woman because of what she's done right
like it it it is what it is right I mean
she's decided to take that step and
create that memory for herself and she
scarred her body with it and I as a guy
if I'm if I'm dating and I were to come
across a woman like that that would to
me put her lower down the totem pole if
there's better women out there that
don't have that baggage like that tattoo
is basically one of the one of the
bricks with the Sharpie written with the
guilt you know or it could be maybe
she's resentful because he left to early
maybe she's guilty because she didn't um
you know remind him to take his medicine
I don't know right but that's that's
what that image represents to a guy that
sees it for what it is right now there's
lots of guys out there that won't even
care they'll just look at it and be like
oh that's nice right but I know what
that means and that tells me that I'm
dealing with an alpha Widow that holds a
place in her heart for this guy and that
to me is well if I'm dating and I've got
a g that doesn't have that baggage I'm
going to pick the G that doesn't have
that baggage over the one with the
baggage because I don't want to be
dealing with that [__] for the rest of
my life I don't want to look at a tattoo
on her body which is now mine reminding
me of some guy that she was with surely
you're never gonna take that man's place
I mean it's it's gonna be a constant
reminder that there is a guy that's
always going to be above you and now he
EX exist in martyrdom essentially um and
there's there's it's no man wants to be
in a relationship where he isn't the
first man in her life and and ideally
the only man in her life but um even the
memory that she holds on to is enough
for to make him second place it's not to
say that she's not worthy of love it's
not to say that she's not worthy of
finding a guy there's lots of guys out
there that that will be with a woman
like that I'm just not one of them and
I'm telling guys why I'm not one of them
and why they should look at it in the
same
light and also I don't think we need to
there's there's we don't need to muddy
muddy the waters with a tattoo here or
there like one or two tattoos versus I
think the point that we brought up is
that excessive you know one of the
things that I've seen in my own dating
life is the cor it's in every in every
situation it's a direct correlation to
the more tattoos she has the more
baggage and Trauma She carries and
there's something about there's
something about you know the thrill or
putting yourself through self-mutilation
or pain that is attractive to these
people because and and if you understand
the human body just at a biological
sense we have antibodies that come in to
fight infection and they we have a
feeling that comes along with that so
there's there's a little bit of euphoria
that comes along let me use a um
well-known example that's in the media
right now so Jada picket Smith and Will
Smith um she's she's now going out there
publicly saying we''ve been sep since
2016 when only a year or two ago he
walked up he he he marched up on on
stage and struck another man because he
made a joke about his what he thought
was his wife at the time Jada pcket
Smith banged her son's best friend and
is constantly talking today about how
she's been Alpha widowed by Tupac Tupac
was my soulmate right so this is where
Will Smith is now in a place of
pain because he accepted this woman into
his life
so my advice to guys from the male
perspective is don't do that become the
best version of yourself level yourself
up be a high value guy have better
options and make better
choices right people are free to do
whatever they want I'm a total
libertarian you wna cut off your dick
you want to become a man you want to do
do it do it fine I don't care that's you
your body a thousand times it doesn't
matter to me but don't expect me to
invite you into my life and introduce
you to my family if you've done stuff
like that don't don't expect me to take
you seriously as a woman or as a
romantic partner if you have a tattoo
with um you know your late husband's
name or a mountain or bird or something
that represents that relationship right
that's how unplugged guys think when
they look at these things we don't
overlook mistakes in people's
lives just like you know women don't
overlook the guy that isn't financially
sorted out when he asks you to pay for
his kid's child childcare you're like
[__] that guy that's not the same at all
it is the same why not it's not the same
a woman tattooing her late husbands no
it's not you look at the guy as an
incompetent douche because he's asking
you to pay for his kids child care I
look at the woman as an incompetent
[__] for tattooing another guy's
momento on her body when she expects me
to accept her into my
life it's not the same thing you're
right but it's the same level of
[__] it's just a level of [__]
that men shouldn't tolerate just like
you won't tolerate paying for a guy's
kid I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out